the Terminator has spawned an entire
entertainment franchise one that
includes films TV series and now defunct
amusement park attractions but as with
any franchise out there
not all installments are created equal
here's how the films and shows stack up
from worst to best the Terminator
franchise had already put out two
immensely successful releases by 2003
when Terminator 3 rise of the machines
came out it marked the first film
without any involvement from series
creator James Cameron it shows rise of
the machines is all style and zero
substance one of those films that throws
everything that worked from its
predecessors at the wall and winds up
making a giant mess with it the chases
are bigger but definitely not better
somehow more explosions happen then in
either previous movie but they don't
seem to be there for any reason other
than someone decided it was a Terminator
movie and Terminator movies need
explosions rise of the machines is
basically the same movie as Judgment Day
only with a female Terminator chasing
after John Connor while Arnold
Schwarzenegger
t800 attempts to protect him just prior
to the release of 2009's Terminator
Salvation machinima released this tie-in
web series Terminator Salvation the
machinima series takes place in 2016
two years prior to the events of
salvation the movie and it centers on
Blair Williams as she sets out on a
mission to hunt down the ghosts a hacker
who's interfering with resistance
communications if he can get past the
mediocre effects the machinima series
manages to be a pretty entertaining
series it doesn't add anything or take
away from the franchise story doesn't
affect the Greater Skynet threat in the
long run but it gets points for
creativity and out of all the Terminator
films the fact that salvation managed to
be the one to get its own offshoot web
series as a marketing ploy is pretty
daring following up rise of the machines
Terminator Salvation tells the bleak
post Judgment Day story of the
resistance and its fighters there were
hopes the film would reinvigorate the
franchise and for a time it seemed as
though it would Jonathan Nolan the
award-winning writer behind The Dark
Knight
interesting
and HBO's Westworld had started work on
the script but pulled out due to another
commitment then there was a writer's
strike salvation just couldn't seem to
catch a break in 2018 star Christian
Bale appeared on MTV's happy sad
confused podcast and touched on his
regrets bale said I said no three times
and it's a great thorn in my side
because I wish we could have
reinvigorated that and unfortunately
during production
you could tell that wasn't happening but
it's a great shame at least salvation
isn't another retelling of the first
three films in this one John Connor is a
fully fledged resistance leader Kyle
Reese is a young pre-time travelling
Sarah Connor romancer and the main
cyborg doesn't even know he's a machine
how about you my name is Marcus right
Thank You Jana I am human Terminator
Genisys the 2015 franchise reboot was
supposed to be the film that really
would bring fans back to the fold even
James Cameron told Yahoo movies that he
felt as though Genesis worked as the
true 3rd installment in the Terminator
franchise with the story centered on
fractured timelines and unexpected
villains Genesis really is the best film
to come out since terminator 2 but
saying that it's better than the two
films before it isn't really saying much
at all the most successful thing about
Genesis is the way it treats its source
material using a combination of fancy
CGI work and reenactments with body
doubles who have just enough like the 84
actors to get by Genesis pays a great
deal of fanservice to those who loved
the original where it fails is in trying
to weave in new material nearly
everything that takes place in the new
2017 timeline is confusing but seeing a
1984 Sarah Connor kick ass kind of makes
up for it for two seasons the Sarah
Connor Chronicles gave fans hope that
the franchise could in fact get back on
track taking place after the events of
Terminator 2 the series sees Sarah and a
teenage John Connor running from yet
another Terminator with the help of a
cyborg named Cameron
get it Cameron the Sarah Connor
Chronicles jumps in time from 1997 to
2007 effectively erasing rise of the
machines Sarah and John are able to
exist in a timeline more in line with
Terminator 2 Sarah is still alive and a
key figure in the resistance star Lena
Headey manages to pick up or Linda
Hamilton left off in a way that feels
more like an homage to the original
character than someone trying to replace
her just before the Terminator hit
theaters in 1984 Orion studio execs
refused to screen it for critics showing
little confidence in it the lack of love
from the studio at the time stuck with
Cameron for over three decades but
looking at the film now it's impossible
to imagine how anyone could consider it
a failure and thankfully audiences at
the time felt the same way the
Terminator launched Cameron's career as
a director and Arnold Schwarzenegger
zazz an actor it was like nothing that
had ever happened in the movies and it
proved that audiences were willing to
shell out their hard-earned money to
watch a diner waitress and her
time-traveling boyfriend get chased
through the streets of Los Angeles by a
cyborg in leather
Cameron told the audience at the fifth
annual hero complex film festival that
the fearlessness it took to make the
Terminator came from his frustration in
trying to break into the industry he
said I was the anonymous kind of angry
wannabe filmmaker there's some courage
that comes from that you say whatever
comes into your head I was kind of like
a free voice in the wilderness in that
stage Terminator 2 Judgment Day not only
builds upon the world created by its
predecessor but it's also somehow better
than the original movie over ten years
after the events of the Terminator Sarah
Connor has been institutionalized
because of her belief in time-traveling
killer robots her son John lives with
foster parents the original t800 has
been reprogrammed as a protector for
John and the new evil is the t1000 an
updated terminator with the added
feature of shape-shifting liquid metal
Judgment Day isn't just a continuation
of the series it's something totally new
Sarah is a fighting machine a far cry
from the scared waitress in the
Terminator
t800 is no longer a threat and this
version of the character sets up a multi
movie arc for the original big bad one
that sees an aging actor continue to
reprise the role in spite of the fact
that robots shouldn't age judgment days
t800 was just so likable it didn't
matter
plus it gave us some fantastic
catchphrases hasta la vista baby
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]